SPEAKER: Companies of all shapes
and sizes across industries
and geographies
have dramatically
accelerated the adoption
of digital during 2020.
As a result, digital
transformation journeys
have been forced to
accelerate over this period,
with years of transformation
being pushed forward
within just a few months.
As APIs are the
fundamental building
blocks of any digital
transformation program,
we at Google Cloud set
out to better understand
the ways in which enterprises
have tracked, deployed,
monitored, and
managed APIs in 2020.
After careful
investigation of this data,
we published a very
insightful report
that speaks to the state
of API economy in 2021.
This report brings together
an in-depth analysis
of over 2 trillion API
calls to better understand
usage behavior on the Apigee
API Management Platform,
a detailed study of customer
use cases seen across GOs
and industries in 2020,
and findings from a survey
administered to over
700 technology leaders
from enterprises
around the world.
Let's take a look
at the findings.
During the last year, despite
the pandemic, nearly 75%
of companies studied
continued focusing
on their digital
transformation initiatives.
And almost 2/3 of
those companies
actually increased their
investments and efforts.
We also saw a
perfect correlation
between the growth
of API traffic
on Apigee and
increased investments
in digital
transformation programs.
Just in 2020, Apigee saw a
whopping 46% year-over-year API
traffic growth, with traffic
volume hitting an all-time high
of 2.2 trillion calls.
With heightened
levels of API usage,
security and privacy of APIs
were of utmost importance
to enterprises.
As a result, anomaly
detection, bot protection,
and security analytics
usage grew by over 230%
across Apigee customers.
And API analytics adoption
increased by over 75%
among Apigee customers.
API security, API
analytics, and API traffic
are just some of the ways
enterprises are investing
in their API
programs as they work
to accelerate their digital
transformation programs.
If you want to learn about
other areas of investment,
then the State of
API Economy Report
is the perfect place to start.
You can download the
executive summary here
at goo.gle/execsumstateofapis,
or download the full State
of API Economy Report here
at goo.gle/stateofapis.
If you want to talk to a Cloud
value advisor about the report
and what the findings
mean to your enterprise,
then ping us at
cloud.google.com/contact.
We hope you enjoyed the
report and we look forward
to connecting with
you at the earliest.
[MUSIC PLAYING]